alors on va faire un truc c'est ce qu'on
va faire l'interview sans la bouche en
bouche marbre dans les tueurs
alors dans un dîner un producteur très
connus vous proposant rôle très
important en vous appelant françoise
toujours dans ce dîner
arrive votre pire ennemi yeux
moufter pas
la bouffe est infect dans ce dîner à
chier
alors bon la bouffe est un fake vous
picoler effectivement un moment vous
allez aux toilettes vous vous trompez de
portes et vous tombez sur un couple deux
mecs en train de baiser
est d'accord à la fin du dîner tout le
monde offre un cadeau aux maîtres de
maison parce qu'en fait ce dîner était
organisé pour son anniversaire vous avez
rien à lui offrir
avant ça suffit
alors vous rentrez chez vous en voiture
les flics vous arrête
ils vous reconnaissez pas
à la lie le reconnaît
en arrivant chez vous il ya une lettre
du laboratoire mettant simplement tine
ouais
d'accord votre fils vous appelle il
pourra pas vous rejoindre cette nuit ça
fait deux fois cette semaine
à votre âge
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu